[Applause]
durant
leonard for three well they're trying to
battle back but it's going to be tough
team just 11 points away
from wrapping things up
[Applause]
63 from the field 49
from three-point line
[Applause]
and a foul on jokic
giannis has had himself quite a night
and he has been
very excitable about it
hey just know i'll be open the guy's in
the
i'll be open every time the guy's in the
face
oh my god oh my god oh my god
[Applause]
oh my god he's pulling he's pulling
oh my god
giannis certainly one of the leading
contenders
for mvp honors here's lillard for three
and this game is three points away
for team lebron
target score 170.
tatum curry with the rebound you know
what's on his mind here it is
for three oh he wanted that for the game
boy he wanted that
you know they're gonna end it on a three
right from half court ridge
so that should be a new rule when you're
up this much you got to end it on a
three if you need three
all right what's lilo thinking about
here
he's thinking about games the three
that's what he's thinking about game
time game time baby
170 150 team lebron
with the victory they win all four
quarters
but by winning the fourth
it's 300 000 for thurgood marshall
college fund and they have done very
well
with 150 000 for the first second and
third quarter and then 300
more here in the fourth 1.25
total for lebron's charity and
how many times have we seen this in big
moments
and playoff moments for dame lillard
what a
shooting display between stephen curry
and dame lillard
both on team lebron putting on
a show
the only thing he didn't do was
but i tell you what just some awesome
moments from these guys that came out
here
and gave the fans what we wanted to see
the mvp presentation coming up giannis
16 for 16
35 points lillard 8 for 16
from three and 32 points